Speaker 1: I think some of you are going to
find this pretty funny. One of the things that,
by the way, speaking of projection, one of the
things the right criticizes the left for is this
idea that anything goes. Any opinion is valid
and they call it a form of postmodernism, where
everyone is supposed to get an equal seat at the
table and we have to listen to all opinions and
value them and consider them all equal. Now it's
not true, it's not true. But as is often the case,
it is they who are doing the very thing which they
accuse others of doing. We call this projection.
Charlie Kirk, a right wing ideologue who speaks
overwhelmingly to college age people and tries to
convince them to become right wingers, he is now
saying inflation may be caused by trans people,
by transgender people. If I've ever seen an
example of this sort of pseudo postmodern,
every opinion is valid. Everything is connected
sort of thing. It's this. Take a listen to this.
This this is this is beyond words.
Speaker 6: So one of the reasons why
we take such a strong stance and opinion on the
trans issue, right is it's an issue of reality.
You do not get to determine your own reality.
Do you not get to all of a sudden say I'm rich
or I'm poor now, we actually have to look at some
evidence of whether or not you're rich or poor.
Now some of those are relative
terms rich, according to WHO. Which,
according to what? I understand that,
but relatively some of the terms we use
short tall. You can't just make them up, you say,
Oh, wow, that person is taller than that person,
that person is faster than that person, they're
stronger than that person. So far, so good.
And one of the reasons why we've been so insistent
against this idea you can change your gender
or change your sex or change both of them is
that when you start to indulge in the belief
that you could become whatever you want? And
reality is subjective, not objective. You're going
to have ramifications that nobody anticipated
or intended. OK, so there is a direct connection
to inflation. And the trans issue. Wow. So,
Charlie, come on, they couldn't be further
apart and they're exactly the same. They're
the same in this aspect. When you believe
that men can become women, why wouldn't you
also believe that you could print wealth?
Oh, man, is it?
Speaker 1: That's rich, isn't it?
Isn't that there's about seven things
that have to be unpacked there.
Speaker 6: If you believe that someone can change
their gender, why wouldn't you also believe
that money is wealth? Now, there
are very simple laws of economics,
just like there's laws of nature. Those laws of
physics, laws of thermodynamics, laws of biology
must lift. We must live according to those laws.
Speaker 1: What's really funny about this is so,
so so let me I'm going to interpret what
he's saying. He says that the ideology
that one can pick their gender. Leads to inflation
in so far as saying you can pick your gender
is like saying you can print money without
causing inflation. Neither is true, but that both
are sort of magical imaginary beliefs not based
in reality. If you believe one, you're likely to
believe the other. If you believe anyone can
pick their gender, you believe you can just
increase the money supply with no effect and
you're likely to do it. The people who believe you
can pick your gender. Are more likely to believe
you can increase the money supply with no effect.
And the problem with this is it's so absurd that
it's hard to even discuss it on its merits. But
the general principle that applies here is
projection because I could turn this around.
This doesn't lead to productive discussion is
the point I'm trying to make. I could turn this
around and go, Listen, Charlie, you know the
idea that you cut taxes for the rich and it
helps the economy that just that's just imaginary,
that's just as imaginary as anything else. And you
can just link to things. You can just link
any of you think if vaccines are related to
trickle down economics. David, what what are you
talking about? Yeah. I mean, listen, if the belief
that the vaccine doesn't work is just as imaginary
as the belief that cutting taxes for the rich
is good for the economy? Oh okay, I've just
linked them. Does this actually substantively
improve our understanding of either of those
issues, vaccination or taxation? No, it doesn't.
And similarly, Charlie Kirk saying, well, the idea
that people can believe things that aren't true
can be used to link any two issues. It doesn't
mean there's actually a connection between trans
and inflation. What's the purpose of this, though?
The purpose is to start grouping ideas they don't
like together, even if they don't actually have
any business being grouped together with the
idea of convincing people by saying, Well, if
you believe either of these things, you have to
believe the other. They must both be wrong, so I
should reject both both beliefs. That's the idea.
It's to weaponize the anti-trans people when it
comes to the economy under Biden or the other
way around to weaponize the economy under Biden to
convince people that they shouldn't be for people
being able to live in the way that aligns with the
way that they feel. So it's bogus. It doesn't lead
to anything productive, but this is the Ben
Shapiro type stuff that you go to a college
campus and people hear and they go, Wow, Charlie's
making a lot of sense there. It really makes a lot
of sense. It's their version of the anything goes
postmodernism that they say exists exclusively on
the left, and they're not going to stop because
this works. He goes to college campuses and he
says this stuff and people just donate. They just
give them money. They give them money, money,
money. It's extremely profitable, it's extremely
effective and it's extraordinarily depressing